hey guys I'm really excited today
because today's video is going to be
somewhat different I'm with a bunch of
Filipino creators not forgetting of
course Jayden all the way from Sydney no
I'm Filipino oh yeah just what today
okay just what today so let me just
explain what we're going to do today as
you can see there are a lot of different
kinds of food so it's going to be
somewhat like an experiment it's going
to be a taste test so nowadays whenever
we do shopping we tend to buy according
to what's written on the food labels
whenever you read that something is
gluten-free low fat less sugar less
sodium 0% fat you tend to think that
it's healthier correct yes and you want
to you know buy that product and you're
willing to pay for a higher price just
because you think that it's healthier so
what we want to do today is that you
will not know which product is you know
full fat which is low fat which is no
sugar and all that so what I want you to
do is just to have a taste tell me which
do you think is sweeter which do you
think is saltier which do you think is
gluten-free and things like that and
that at the end we will review what is
what on the food label okay
so it's really all about using your
palate it's really about tasting it and
just be honest you know which one would
you buy which one would you go for okay
so are we all excited yeah right so why
don't we start from the strawberry jam
that we have here one of them has no
added sugar at all so it's just pure
strawberry jam the other one has added
sugar just taste it and then we'll move
on to the other strawberry jam and then
you can compare okay mmm and let's try
the other one which one do you think is
sweeter the first one or the second one
the first one is sweeter okay which do
you prefer the second one okay and which
do you think has no added sugar
the second one the second one okay who
stays the first one that's no added
sugar how many one two three no added
sugar added sugar whose day is the
second one me so the one that has no
added sugar is actually the first one
yeah okay the second one has added sugar
yeah when it comes to buying Jam I would
definitely recommend getting gem that
has no added artificial sugar because
natural sugar from fruits is where
healthier that having added white sugar
okay right let's go on to the next one
let's do the cookies one bowl is your
normal cookies okay another bowl is a
gluten-free version so which one is
gluten-free the smaller the bigger one
the bigger one okay so which one is
sweeter which one do you think is higher
in fat the bigger one is high in fats
yeah so basically the bigger is bad
that's why I say right so the smaller
ones is gluten-free the bigger one is
your normal cookie mm-hmm however you
don't need to eat gluten free products
if you're not gluten intolerance because
the bigger one actually has less sugar
less sodium and less fat so the
gluten-free products in order to you
know add more flavors to it it actually
has more sugar more fat and more sodium
so don't be fooled by duty-free products
let's move on to the yogurt so one
version is your normal food fat yogurt
the other version has zero percent fat
labeled on it well
which one is creamier
and second one I think is you think so
first one is creamier second one it's
creamy on this side okay so which one do
you think has 0% fat labeled on it the
first one or the second one first one 0%
fat
second one is basically fou fats yeah
right so you guys got it right so the
first one is actually 0% fat and the
second one is full fat but saying that
however whenever you buy food products
like disappointed yes it is 0% fat but
most of the times they will add sugar
into it to substitute for the flavors or
it will be high in sodium as well sodium
sugar will tend to be higher in order to
make it taste better because they are
removing the fat from the product and
the full fat version has high protein
the 0% fat tend to have lower protein
yeah so it's very important for you to
flip the products around and compare the
food labels don't just see the front
part or 0% fat let me just grab that
flip it around and actually compare the
calories and the protein the salt and
sugar as well okay right
do you like a teacher today granola bars
and do you think that these bars are
healthy for you you think so do you
think it's like a quick energy fix when
you need energy yes tell me which one do
you think has sugar added to it and
which one has no sugar added to it who
says the one on the right has no sugar
added to it you you you okay three and
so the rest of you you think that this
has no sugar this one actually you're
like which one II you love granola okay
so the one on the right actually has no
sugar added to it this one has your
wife's you gotta to it bad that's always
a bar to everything
why does it taste so sweet what do you
think it tastes so sweet no because it
has artificial sugar as well it has like
a sugar substitute if you want to go for
granola bars try to go for the one that
uses honey right or like maple syrup
rather than white sugar or some sugar
substitute and go for the one that says
with or oats as the first ingredient
if he says sugar as the first ingredient
or another kind of sugar substitute as
the first ingredient avoid that right
let's have some big beans now so for the
baked beans one is your normal big beans
the other one is a reduced salt baked
beans is there a huge difference when
you taste it no not really a little bit
on the aftertaste
okay who says the first one is the
normal version you the normal version so
the rest of you you think that the first
one is the salt reduced version yes do
you think the second one is a soul
reduce so the first one is actually the
salt reduced version in this case yes go
for the salt reduced version most of the
time they tend to add a lot of salt into
your canned food in order to preserve
the food so when you can look for salt
reduced version for canned food go for
it okay let's just you know clasp our
palate drink some juice right now so I'm
gonna pass
two cups each so one is 100% orange
juice the other one has added sugar so
which one then the thicker one or the
more diluted one do you think is the
100% orange juice thicker one is 100%
yeah yeah the one with the yep I mean
the thinner one is basically yeah
artificial which one do you think has
higher sugar content the natural one
yeah actually sure this okay and you
guys got that right
so yeah the thicker one has higher sugar
content because it is 100% natural the
one has added white sugar it is more
diluted because the first ingredient is
actually water so probably when you buy
it it'll be cheaper as well yeah so in
this case I would say spend that little
extra to get what's good for you okay
sometimes it is worth spending that
little extra at least you know that and
they're not cheating you by adding more
water and then just adding more sugar
and then only orange okay so go for 100%
natural Oh
forgettin about me Oh so one version is
actually your normal full fat version
the other one has no egg so it's
actually a vegetarian version no egg at
all and it is also reduced fat who says
the yellow one has egg yellow one yellow
one has egg okay all of you are correct
in regards to the yellow one has egg the
white one is the vegetarian version it
has less fat compared to the yellow one
if you really want to reduce your
calories and if you really want to cut
down any calories but at the same time
you like your Mayo because one
tablespoon of mayo has more than 100
calories tablespoon okay whereas the
white no egg version has about thirty
nine calories per tablespoon it is too
high but it is way less compared to the
full fat version if you're eating salad
if you're eating really healthy be aware
of your sources be aware of your
dressings
you might be thinking yes I'm eating
salad it's so healthy next thing is like
all the sauces like yeah let me put more
sauce on to it your the amount of sauce
you're putting onto your salad might
contain more calories compared to your
entire salad bowl one final drink this
is really a coke challenge really it's
one it's just the normal coke one is a
zero coke who can tell just by looking
at it which one zero which one here or
here
oh my god so yes right hand is the cook
zero left is the full sugar coke if you
really like your cook and you really
want to drink it
obviously the zero version will be
better for you in a sense that it
contains zero calories but still be
aware of it because artificial sugar
substitute can still cause belly fat
although it has no calories but when you
drink this chances are you might want to
have other kind of sugary stuff to go
along with it if you can avoid it
completely if you can't then yes choose
the zero version and she's drinking like
the fool blue sugar version right now
she's like yeah it's good okay the most
important thing is when you do your
grocery shopping always look at the food
labels always look at the ingredients
list and read that don't be fooled by
what the marketing people want you to
believe in don't be fooled by you know
whatever you see in front and whatever
that looks really fancy okay be sure to
turn around flip around read all the
nutritional values read the ingredients
list and avoid anything that has sugar
as the first ingredient okay and yeah
thank you so much I've had a lot of fun
thank you and yeah let's do burpees guys
if you enjoyed this video then like it
share it and subscribe to my youtube
channel for more exercises healthy
recipes and fitness tips all the best